why is it that when you build
um a
technologically sophisticated telescope
that can peer out into the vast depths
of space that you're also looking back
in time
so all telescopes are time machines of A
Sort and that's by virtue of the fact
that light as fast as it travels and it
is the fastest propagating
entity that we know about in all of
science it travels about this far about
one foot every nanosecond so if you
convert you know nanoseconds to Miles
and you convert uh you know a feet to
miles and nanoseconds to seconds it
travels about 186 000 miles per second
which is pretty darn fast but it's not
infinite so therefore whenever you're
looking at something you're not seeing
it as it is right now you're seeing it
as it was sometime in the past and the
farther away something is the longer the
light travel to reach your eyes or to
reach our telescopes and telescopes are
just eyes of a different sort there
might be sensitive to microwaves in the
case of the telescope that I build radio
waves gamma rays but just like your
eyeballs your eyeballs are too
refracting telescope Scopes they have
lenses they have detectors and so when
we look at the Sun and I'm not
advocating as a professional astronomer
never look at the sun with your
remaining good eye but when you look at
the sun you're seeing it as it was and
that period in which it was was eight
minutes ago because it's 93 million
miles away and if you convert feet per
nanosecond or miles per second or miles
per hour you get it takes about eight
minutes for light to travel from the Sun
that means that Jordan the sun could
disappear and we wouldn't see it and we
wouldn't know about it really for at
least eight minutes and maybe even
longer so all telescopes are time
machines even the telescopes embedded in
our skulls
so how far back can we look now with for
example with the web telescope and
that's the new newest large scale deep
peering telescope that was launched into
space and
um how far back have we pushed the
Horizon of view now
so yes the James Webb Telescope was
launched on Christmas Day and 2021 and
it's been sending back phenomenal images
what makes the web telescope so powerful
is not that it can see farther back in
time although it can in a certain sense
but it doesn't have extra magnification
and that's not required to see things
that are farther away in other words if
you use a tiny little telescope like the
sort that Galileo used back in 1609 to
spot the craters on the moon's surface
you could use uh the the Hubble
telescope can also look at the Moon and
it won't see things that are it'll see
more detail on the moon's surface but it
won't see farther than the moon because
the Moon is in the way now if you look
where there's no moon where there's no
planet where there's no galaxies where
there's no absorbing matter whatsoever
then you're seeing back to the creation
of whatever light your telescope is
sensitive to now visible light has only
been around for a few billion years
because before that time because of the
universe is expand tension that light
has red shifted it has gone from visible
light to infrared light which is
invisible to our eyes but highly visible
and that is the Quarry that the web
telescope is seeking now if you go
farther than the infrared then you come
to microwaves which is what I study so
the longer the wavelength the light
you're looking at the farther you can go
back in time not because you're impeded
by something but because the source the
very source that you're looking at has
been diminished in intensity and has
been readden by the expansion of the
universe which is a phenomenal discovery
that we've only known about for less
than 100 years but because of that
Universal expansion we can only see
using particular wavelengths of light
and so that's why the earliest light in
the universe there's no light that we
could ever see that is more primitive
than the cosmic microwave background
that I and my colleagues are studying so
the web telescope can't see far back in
time as we can but that's really
irrelevant it's designed to do something
very specific look at the first galaxies
that form the first stars that formed
exoplanets in other Stellar solar
systems in our own Galaxy and because of
that it's a phenomenal machine and is
unrivaled in its capability
so what what uh element of the let's
let's have you explain what the
electromagnetic spectrum is because
people are not going to necessarily know
what the relationship is say between
visible light and and and microwave
radiation they might not know that those
are very varying forms of radiation that
is very similar in its Essence and also
to explain why the red shift occurs
and how that was discovered I suppose
yes yes
so a spectrum is a characteristic of
light light has three major properties
that we uh that we discuss as scientist
one is its intensity how bright the
light is and the other is the color of
the light and the third is something
called polarization which happens to be
my area of subspecialty not political
polarization but it's an actual useful
form of polarization that has to do with
the orientation of the electromagnetic
field but all forms of light now people
hear radiation and they get scared did
the bomb go off is there some nuclear
reaction I don't know has nothing to do
with that it's just a generic term that
scientists call light of different
wavelengths so if you imagine a rainbow
which has an infinite number of colors
there's people say there's seven colors
the famous Roy G Biv we learned about in
elementary school maybe but there's
actually an infinite number of colors
because uh the number that describes the
color of light is called its wavelength
and the wavelength of light is a
continuous number it can be any number
can have any number of decimal places so
it's a continuous number therefore
there's an infinite number of real
numbers therefore the spectrum is not
discrete in seven different increments
so now imagine you go beyond the red
color you keep going to the left of that
red color and actually this was an
experiment done by a very famous
scientist and in Herschel and even Isaac
Newton did similar types of experiments
where they took the sunlight they
refracted it through a prism so we've
all seen these prisms that disperse
light and they had light of different
colors coming out at different angles
and that's the property of a prism that
causes it to make a rainbow from
ordinary white light and what Newton and
Herschel did is they put a thermometer
they went into the red light and they
put a bulb of an ordinary thermometer
and they kept moving it until it got
beyond the red and then they found that
beyond the red color there was still
something coming in causing the Mercury
to rise in this thermometer so there was
clear there was other light of a longer
wavelength they knew about the
wavelength of light and that longer
wavelength is what we associate with
heat now the opposite side if you go
past the Violet side of Roy G Biv
you come to something called ultraviolet
ultraviolet is also invisible and we
know about that from the Sun the
sunlight produces damaging UVA and UVB
radiation uh that's not any different
except for the fact it buys
characteristic wavelengths it's
wavelength is shorter than violet light
infrared is longer than uh than red
light and if you keep going in both
directions there's photons and
wavelengths of light in all different
directions add infinitum to the to the
high frequency or short wavelength and
it goes to Infinity in the other
direction you can have infinitely long
and that'll be called a radio wave so
that's the electromagnetic spectrum now
if you've ever listened uh to a a siren
approaching you've heard the familiar
Doppler shift that's interesting Doppler
Christian Doppler and Wolfgang Mozart
grew up in the same town in Salzburg
Austria I like to think they're they're
kind of enjoying the the irony of that
fact that they both have this
fascination with sound uh and its
phenomena and the expansion or dilution
of the wavelength of light is exactly
the result of a Doppler shift which is
exactly analogous to the the increase in
pitch and the decrease in Pitch that one
hears when an ambulance first approaches
you with its siren on that pitch is
increased and that's called a blue shift
meaning it goes to Shorter sound
wavelengths or it goes to higher pitches
as it goes away the opposite phenomenon
happens and that's why you hear this
characteristic rise
as it moves away from you and that's an
analog of red well the same thing
happens in light